[Music]
i see you maybe three times a week
in the gym we both uh shoot our shows
here at the warner brothers lot there's
one gym and i see you i think i see you
there quite a bit it's a thank you uh
okay uh
um i i'm not doing much no i know i'm
hanging out no they have reading and
exactly exactly the magazines uh because
they're old and dog-eared wonderful uh
but no they just redid the thing with
these gorgeous uh wall high pictures of
you know hillary swank and million
dollar baby so she's a boxer you know
and chadwick boseman from uh from the
the jackie robinson movie you know
sliding into second and they're just uh
they have clint eastwood a giant clint
eastwood on the wall is scowling and
you're there doing your
we're doing our weights there and he
looks like he's just mad at us
well i think it's uh you know it's it's
honoring the contributions of actors to
sports yes um
you know
it took a little while benny
uh obviously there we have none we have
actors do not actually make
contributions to sports but i but
whenever i see you in there it's always
a little odd because uh i go there
around um
in the morning and uh and you're always
uh standing there
looking upward at the tv screens because
there's lots of tv screens uh at uh the
view yes and you are
absolutely transfixed that show
fascinates me exactly and but you're
kind of there's a sadness to it if i may
it's just this this is
john is being at he's telling the
absolute truth andy you've seen me in
the gym and whenever the view's on i
stand there and i just look up at it and
i'm like how do i get into that kind of
tv i'm sick of trying to make people
laugh
at tv where look why don't we just sit
get six people together and we have
coffee and we just chat yeah and then
you get that check and you're like see
your suckers
that's the kind of tv i want in on i
always thought that you were just
forlornly i thought you were missing joy
behar
sure
yeah
uh wasn't that no no no no but uh
but no i i i do get but you work out
pretty hard i have to say i i yeah i
sweat a lot i swear like it's very
intimidating
the atmosphere in there mostly because
you know richter runs that joint like uh
yeah like schwarzenegger back in the day
you know it's it's like the miami
dolphins locker room over there
i'm i'm retiring on your lunch money
[Laughter]
andy is the bully of the lunch room yeah
yes absolutely you know it's like if
you're if he's spotting you he's going
to drop the weights on you you got to
know that you got to know that that's
going to i have to say i did really see
this happen i saw you uh i think i saw
you on the treadmill once and the pretty
and pink theme came on and i couldn't i
swear to god i heard the pretty and pink
theme and i saw you when you were on the
treadmill and i thought this is such a
weird
i can't remember which one uh we you
have
i made it up uh
you had crazy hair
uh in that movie yeah
look at the hair
uh was it just a spectacular mane yeah
unruly wonderfulness yeah and and it's
gone now
i don't know you still have well a head
of hair no this is an elaborate illusion
uh there's not very this is the work of
several talented professionals making
the most of like four hairs seriously
it's it no it's amazing actually what
they can do uh i'm not wearing a piece
or anything like that um but it's a long
involved process uh that starts with
stuff that's uh
like shoe polish basically uh that they
coat your scalp at the top you may want
to get do we have a camera up here sure
why not see here we go oh [ __ ] they do a
this is a satellite yeah
they do a beautiful our second guest is
making this and so they they paint they
they basically just paint they get a
roller type thing yeah and just whoosh
uh along the top there and you have to
decide you don't have a roller you get
they you get a painter in there yes you
get a painter in there and you know they
dip it in and you know and then swoosh
whoosh and uh you have to decide whether
you're gonna go you know full travolta
and uh
and get like the full uh front in um and
then they they literally sprinkle powder
in like from a salt shaker uh and and so
so that this this is as i said it's it's
four or five total hairs there's a
powder that's been up there's this is
how we're going to shoot all talk shows
now just that shot
so tell us john hurry up how's it going
so there's a powder in there does that
now what happens if you're out in the
world and it's i don't know it's raining
or you're on a trampoline oh you're out
of luck
is what happens uh it it flattens out
and you can get the nice little rivulets
going down
uh but thankfully your eyebrows will
channel it
uh down so if it rains you get really
thick eyebrows what you're saying
you become a caveman starts to rain